they come with the little they could
save from their homes they come in their
thousands every day the border between
South Sudan and Uganda is controlled but
officials there let all refugees through
almost a million people have fled war
and famine ridden South Sudan four
neighboring Uganda they are desperate
and exhausted Uganda has a model refugee
policy after being registered in a camp
most refugees are given a piece of land
like here in the north of the country
maria lalume and her grandchildren have
been here since the beginning of the
year our Bureau it's the third time I've
had to leave my country firstly because
of the conflict with Sudan and now this
war yalli both my children and my
grandchildren were born in refugee camps
only a really solid government could
convince me to return to my home country
but I don't think that will happen in my
lifetime back despite the small piece of
land life here is hard
Meriel alone has to get by with just
four kilos of corn flour a week for
eight people still after being separated
while fleeing the family is happy to
just be together after South Sudan
gained independence in 2011 hopes for
peace were high but the people were to
be bitterly disappointed when just two
years later the country descended into
civil war our hope was for our
development of our countries and to make
the good relationships and the business
along our neighbours but they have to
really see the struggle of the people
the suffering
Uganda's open-door policy is
increasingly proving a strain on the
country it now desperately needs
international aid to cope with the new
arrivals when you integrate refugees
with the hospital ation you cannot
discriminate you want that ability to
provide services to to both host
populations and refugees at the same
time given the economic situations in
all our developing world countries we
are already struggling water for example
is in short supply in the north of the
country adequate supplies of food
schools and medicine are needed for
hundreds of thousands of people but
despite the strain Uganda's door remains
open to those in need